[Musique]
pour la journée de la femme les
finalistes du prix seligmann se sont
retrouvés à l'hémicycle du département
le point commun avec tous ces visages
c'est leur détermination à s'exprimer
par l'art un regard très admiratif est
très satisfaisant puisque moi je suis
artiste graffeuse donc je trouve que
c'est super de mettre en avant des
artistes amateurs
j'étais très surprise aussi de la
qualité et du niveau de créativité et de
tous les supports qui ont été utilisés
c'était une expérience très
enrichissante
[Musique]
la centaine de participantes n'a pas
démérité et c'est maintenant la
tradition un prix des collégiens
accompagne ce concours le collège
leconte de lisle à saint louis gagne le
premier prix parmi huit autres
établissements avec vénus collection le
nul parfois choqué fait rire
or là c'était vraiment quelque chose de
naturel ils ont enlevé au fur et à
mesure ils ont fait ressortir ressortir
ses formes généreuses nous en fait la
consigne qu'on avait eue c'était de
représenter la femme de la faire comme
nous on la voit et
du coup vu que nous on la voit forte
quand même que les courageuses du coup
de chance qu'on a essayé de mettre ça
dans nos heures
[Musique]
non sans émotion chaque candidate reçoit
alors les différents prix l'occasion de
parler de leurs oeuvres
la transmission de leurs sentiments oui
on doit laisser la parole aux femmes
qu'aux vide ou pas pandémie ou pas
quelle que soit la crise
il n'y a jamais de bonnes raisons de
priver les femmes de leur parole donc
évidemment le prix a été maintenue
elles ont des choses à exprimer des
pensées à exprimer une critique du monde
aussi quelquefois exprimer et c'est bon
signe c'est la simplicité et le message
de l'oeuvre de julie olivier qui a fait
la différence
cette mère de famille de saint benoît
touche à tous les arts mais sans perdre
le lien avec la réalité des femmes
nous sommes parfois est très souvent
même encore des meufs j'ai tjrs evans
d'une façon un peu plus moderne et
ordonné que à travers les réseaux la
société les jugements des autres on ne
pousse à aider mais parfaite à
ressembler à des modèles standardisés
alors que nous sommes qui nous sommes
mais comme nous sommes est tout
simplement voilà l'exposition de la
centaine d'oeuvres qui ont participé à
cette 17e édition est visible jusqu'au
23 mars 2021 à la villa du département
[Musique]